So we've talked a little bit about the kind of simple code that you would use to get some of this stuff working but it's worth actually looking at the editor itself.
The easiest way to make a widget is through the actual Blueprint content flow.
You can again make classes that inherit from these things in C++ but just as a kind of quicker way to demonstrate it.
If we go to... I'm just going to go into the 1.1.0.5 folder because you know that's at least vaguely the right area.
But you would go to User Interface here by right-clicking and go to Widget Blueprint.
And then you're presented with a class selector very much like when you're making an actor class.
Or, well, just a new Blueprint, sorry.
But you'll see that the hierarchy is slightly different.
Again, we've got our visual as our root.
And then we have Widget.
And again, you'll note that neither of these two things are viable options to select from.
It's only at the point that we select User Widget that we can actually create an instance of this class.
And if we were then to select that, we would then get that new widget created for us.
So if I just called this BP underscore My New Widget.
Although I say BP, actually the typical naming convention would either be WBP for Widget Blueprint.
Or sometimes if you want to be a little bit more shorthand, W underscore Widget.
In my own work, I've typically used double W to say that this is a Blueprint-only widget.
And WPP to indicate that this is a Widget Blueprint that inherits from C++.
From a C++ widget that isn't just User Widget, but is my own C++ class.
But that is purely my own workflow kind of thing.
So that's not necessarily something you need to adopt yourselves.
So just talking through the window that we'll see when we first open our widget up.
I will quickly do this just to show you that we are talking about the same screen here.
But it's kind of easier to go with the presentation where we've got this kind of markup on all of these sections.
So right at the top of the section we've got our kind of standard toolbar.
This is pretty much as we would expect to find really across all the engine.
And most pieces suffer to be honest, like our file edit section.
Some of these things do apply are kind of semi-contextual.
So they may have options that aren't necessarily available outside of UMG.
So just kind of worth mentioning that.
Underneath we've got the point where they start to get a little bit more specific to UMG.
So we've got the toolbar. This contains a kind of number of common functions.
We've obviously got our save, our search, compiling our Blueprint, diff.
So this is obviously only going to be relevant when we're connected to source control.
But you can diff both Blueprints and user widgets.
It's actually got quite developed functionality.
This didn't always used to be as good as it is now.
But you can diff widgets quite successfully with each other.
They're particularly good at diffing the code itself, the Blueprint code.
Changes to the actual widget hierarchy are represented.
And you can see differences in the values and any widgets you might have added.
The visualization of them isn't quite so developed.
So it's not perfect, but it will get you a long way there.
And the information is available to you there.
So that's a lot more helpful than it not being there.
Then we've got our standard play in editor.
Next we have our dropdown.
So this would be familiar to anyone who's spent this time working with debugging actors.
But this is just to select an instance.
So if, for example, you're debugging a widget and there are two copies of that widget,
because you're creating two health bars, one for each player,
you could select which of the two health bars you're trying to debug at the moment.
Then we have our widget reflector, which is a button that is unique to UMG.
And it's worth just mentioning this because it's a very, very powerful tool.
I'll talk a little bit more about this, but it is worth checking this out.
This is essentially a debugging tool that lets you kind of debug what you're seeing at runtime.
I'll come back to this in a little bit, but just worth at least mentioning that there is a button to open up your widget reflector.
It can also be done through a console command, which is, again, we'll circle back to this towards the end of the presentation.
But if this is actually the example of my networking course, but it's kind of not too important.
If I just go to widget reflector and type that in a console command, you can also open the widget reflector this way.
It's open on my other screen, but you just have to trust me that opened.
So, yeah, we'll circle back to that.
So, yes, that's kind of second section in the top right.
We've got the switcher that lets us switch between our designer, which is the kind of more UMG.
Yeah, the more UMG kind of unique view where we're kind of doing all the visual editing and our graph view,
which is going to look a lot more like a standard typical blueprint graph view.
So if you spent any time editing blueprints, that's graph is going to look a lot more like the other blueprints you would have worked in before.
And yeah, so it's going to have the same things exposed.
There are functions, variables and really access to any of the kind of C++ behaviour,
whether that's, you know, you would also be exposing any kind of C++ functionality or variables for any class we might have inherited from there.
Then on the back over to the left here, we've got our fourth section.
This is the palette. This is essentially, well, as the name kind of implies,
it's a palette of pre-made widgets that we can use to define the kind of structure
that we can build up a more complex picture for what our widget actually looks like.
Really, this will show anything that inherits from UWidget.
Some of the kind of common things is containers such as vertical and horizontal boxes,
scroll boxes, overlays, borders, spaces. We've kind of already talked about a lot of these.
It'll also contain any user-generated widgets at the point that you make your own user blueprints.
They will come out in their own section here.
And yeah, I kind of think that's everything really to say about palette. Below the palette, we've also got the hierarchy.
So where palette is the kind of options available to us for the widgets that we can drag in,
our hierarchy actually represents our current view of our widget as it is designed.
So this is the kind of like the tree that defines how our widget is actually laid out.
So kind of getting into the detail of the hierarchy is maybe something better done in live.
But this would look a little bit similar to maybe if you've worked in DCC packages before
or in your blueprint editor when you're adding scene components.
This is in a hierarchy, so widgets can be inside of other widgets.
It depends on the kind of widget type, whether or not a widget can have no widgets within it,
whether it can have several or just one. But typically a kind of more complicated hierarchy would have several elements in it.
In fact, if I just quickly jump over to a pre-existing example.
So if I go to our health bar widget and I go to a segmented bar widget.
Oh, that's too simple. Do I have any? Oh, I definitely do.
If I go to focus navigation, this is what a kind of slightly more complicated hierarchy might actually look like.
Where you have, again, hierarchy being the key here.
We've got these dropdowns for where widgets are socketed inside of other widgets.
So we have a horizontal box containing several elements.
We have a vertical box containing several elements.
You can even have, you know, a vertical box containing a horizontal box containing a scroll box.
So, you know, we're not limited to kind of one level of depth here in one.
And you can kind of infer that from the fact that we have everything inside a canvas panel.
So we've already got at least three layers of depth here.
So this is, again, just the kind of editor time representation of how this widget might look.
Obviously, there's still the capacity here to add new widgets at runtime.
So this is only the kind of more static version of this widget.
If you're adding things at runtime, then that's obviously not going to be able to be reflected here.
So I think that's our hierarchy.
Then, yes, section six is basically just our visual designer.
So this is a visual representation of everything that's in our hierarchy.
Again, just to quickly jump over, we can see for every widget that is represented in our hierarchy,
that is selectable and visualizable here.
We have various settings to control this space.
So this is a little bit like a canvas for us to drag things into.
You can define things like the kind of size of this area by default.
But between the two of these, this is a little bit like a world eyeliner,
whereas this is a kind of game viewpoint if you want to turn it into a level of context.
And working between the two can be quite a potent way to navigate between things that either might be hidden
or just a little bit easy to jump back and forth between finding things
and then clicking on the bits that are visually relevant.
Yeah, and then last of all, we've got the details panel, which will be familiar to anyone who's spent any time working in the world outliner or the level editor.
And it does the kind of same job here.
So for any item that you currently have selected, the details panel will display all of the variable,
all the bits of information, all the variables about that particular widget in a kind of editable way.
Typically for widgets, this might be things like colour pickers, this might be various values that you've set, bits of information relevant to the slots.
We've already talked about this idea of, sorry, jumping ahead a slide, we've already talked about this idea of slots for panels,
but it's just worth quickly touching on that, actually, that when something that is kind of a little bit more different about UMG that you might not necessarily get used to
is that when you're looking at any given widget, usually one of the first things you'll see is the slot.
This is not information that is specific to this type of widget.
This slot information is made available to it based on the widget that is inside of.
So this exact same, this is a, well, if I go to like a text widget here, for example, you can see that we've got the slot, which is a horizontal box slot.
If I drag this text widget inside the canvas panel, now it doesn't have a horizontal box slot anymore, it has a canvas panel slot.
So whereas the rest of the details panel is kind of talking about this widget itself,
if this widget is inside a panel, which the vast majority of widgets are, the vast majority of the time,
the kind of first section tends to be describing the slot, which is information about the thing it is inside of
and what capabilities it has to kind of control the way it's laid out within that thing.
So within the context of a horizontal box, you can say, you know, is this thing trying to demand its own space?
Is it trying to fill up all the space available?
How much padding does it have from nearby content from the kind of slot that's been given to it?
Should it try and lay itself out like centered? Should it try and fill the entire space?
Should it lay itself out vertically centered, et cetera, et cetera, et cetera?
It very much depends contextually on what kind of panel it's inside of for what information is available to it through the slot.
And then last of all, we have the animation window.
So this won't necessarily appear straight away.
I think typically when you open the UMG editor, it's not actually going to be there, but it's just down here in this little dropdown.
So this is kind of an expandable window.
This is a little bit like the content drawer.
If you press control space, it will just temporarily open up.
I think control shift space opens up the animation window.
But if you are doing a lot of animation authoring that can come and become a little bit irritating.
There is also this docking layout, which will actually turn into a kind of like a sticky window that will actually just continue perpetually sit in your editor unless you then just choose to close that window.
So this is where you would author any animations where you would key various frames and just do all your animation kind of layout functionality.
We'll touch a little bit more on animations later and we'll circle back to that.
So if we were to just quickly go through a demonstration of how one might actually use some of this stuff.
We've got some GIFs here in the presentation, but I figure I might as well kind of just do this live because it's a little bit easier.
So we can see that it's very easy to kind of put content into a new widget.
If I would just go back to that new widget we've made.
Like I said, we've got our palette here. We've got a couple of different options.
Typically you would put in some kind of root panel because normally the first thing you want in your widget isn't a widget that can't have anything else attached to it.
It's something that can have something attached to it.
So the kind of standard go-to is a canvas panel because canvas panels give you a lot of control.
It's just worth mentioning that canvas panels are about the least efficient widget to use.
So one should be a little bit cautious about using them if you don't need to.
But just for the purposes of demonstration, it's quite an easy one to use.
Canvas panels are essentially a panel that can have as many children as they like in it.
But they also give that child a lot of control over how it's laid out within that widget.
So if I was to take an image and you can see I can either drag items from my palette into my hierarchy like this.
Or I can drag them out into my visual editor like this and I'm kind of positioning it and adding it at the same time.
A lot of the kind of standard shortcuts here work as well.
So if I press control D, that's going to duplicate it.
I think by default it does tend to snap it to the top left.
So that's just a little kind of like eccentricity that's worth bearing in mind.
And then as you can see, by editing this, I'm affecting its slot because canvas slots have a pixel coordinate from the top left of the screen.
But you can also, I say the top left is also kind of like an anchor that says, you know, where, how do its coordinates describe itself in relation to a certain section of the screen?
So you can use this in a way to say that, you know, this widget should always be in the centre of the screen exactly.
You could set its anchor to the centre and have it at 0, 0.
And there's a couple of additional things to bear in mind, like alignment.
So if I said that this is aligned 0.5, 0.5, that would be truly in the centre.
So, yeah, worth experimenting.
And a lot of these settings are going to be dependent based on what kind of panel you're working within.
But canvas is the one that gives you the most control.
You can easily resize things and it gives you a lot of flexibility and control.
But again, canvases are probably the most expensive widget to use, so they should be used with a certain degree of caution.
And then, yeah, we already talked about the fact that when we search over into our graph view, we have something that looks a lot more like our standard Blueprint code.
We have a couple of nodes available to us.
This is like, we will talk a little bit more about what these actually do a little bit later.
But, you know, where we typically see our begin play and tick when you're in UMG, this would actually be construct and tick.
But we'll talk about those in a little bit more detail in a little bit.